THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
I AGREE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BOROUGH.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
RADIO.
SO BONTA THIS.
CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHAUDHRY KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRASER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
WE KNOW.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS REYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOULD.
MISTER SPEAKER
PRESIDENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND.
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB WELSH TOUGH
REFERRED TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
LAST MONTH I SHARED THAT OUR
PREVIOUS BISHOP AND MY DEAR
FRIEND SO CHOI COURSING OR
AGREE.
WILL BE RETIRING FROM ACTIVE
MINISTRY FROM THE TEMPLE IN THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON. AND HE'LL
BE RETURNING TO KYOTO JAPAN.
I'VE ALWAYS ADMIRED HIS NATURE
TO SIMPLY ENGAGE THE WORLD WITH
GENUINE CURIOSITY AND HONESTY.
SO TO AGREE ONE SHARED WITH ME
THAT WHILE IN CHICAGO HE HAILED
A CAB TO TAKE HIM TO THE COUNCIL
OF THE PARLIAMENT OF WORLD
RELIGIONS.
SINCE HE WAS WEARING HIS
PRIESTLY ROBES.
THE TAXI DRIVER ASKED HIM. ARE
YOU GOING TO THE PARLIAMENT OF
WORLD RELIGIONS.
SO TO ANSWER YES.
THE TAXI DRIVER THEN ASKED.
DO THINK THAT PEACE WILL COME TO
THIS WORLD.
SO TWO REPLIED.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE TAXI DRIVER SEEMED HAPPY
WITH THIS RESPONSE. THEN
PERCEPTIBLY ASKED
THEN WHAT ARE YOU DOING. YOU'RE
WASTING YOUR TIME GOING TO THIS
COUNCIL.
SO TWO OF WE REPLIED. BUT AT
LEAST I'M PAYING YOU FOR DRIVING
ME IN YOUR TAXI.
THE TAXI DRIVER LOOKED BACK AT
HIM AND THEY BOTH LAUGHED.
THEN SO TO A SAID.
HEY LOOK AT US.
AT THIS MOMENT WE'RE LAUGHING
TOGETHER.
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP FOR PEACE
BETWEEN PEOPLE.
THE TAXI DRIVER SAID A YEAR AN
INTERESTING GUY. AND HE LAUGHED
AGAIN.
SO TO A SAID WE WERE ABLE TO
SHARE A MOMENT OF PEACE WITHOUT
MUCH CONSCIOUSNESS OR EFFORT.
WITH HONESTY AND LAUGHTER THEY
WERE ABLE TO CONNECT WITH THEIR
SHARED HUMANITY.
CONNECTING WITH OTHERS.
REALIZING OUR SHARED HUMANITY.
IS A GOOD FIRST STEP TOWARDS OUR
OWN PEACE OF MIND.
HARMONY WITHIN OUR FAMILIES AND
PEACE ON EARTH.
NUMBER ONE.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CABALLERO AS SHE LEAVES US IN
THE PLEDGE MISS CUMPLIR.
PLEASE JOIN US AS WE. PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG. READY
BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SAN.
MISSION.
IT IS. RETAINING ASSETS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
I READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE CEMENT AT SEVEN AM
THE OUT OF A ROCKET TO CHAVEZ
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HAVE A SIX DISC
RESIDING SHE FLIRTED ALSO WAS IN
THE BEST RECORD. IN THOSE
READING THE FOLLOWING REPLACE
MULLIN MORNING ROLL CALL
CONSUMMATE. GIPSON MOVES.
MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
COOLEY AND MCCARTY.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MR.
CHáVEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
RECORD I I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN A.
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
KANSEN CHU COOPER AND MATHIS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THAT SHOULD BE THE ORDER. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SPEAKER HOLDEN JONES SAWYER AND
MULLIN TO HAVE.
SPEAK ON INTERMINABLY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SP TWO SEVENTY FIVE
HUSING.
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN I AM
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE ITEM A EIGHTEEN AS BEFORE
SIXTY FIVE JACKSON. FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE.
CLERK WILL NOTE
MEMBERS VERY BRIEFLY A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT.
OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON
CELEBRATED HIS FIFTIETH
BIRTHDAY.
THAT WAS YESTERDAY MISTER
SPEAKER.
AS
. BE. HAVING MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER KANSEN CHU FROM MY DESK
ON THE FLOOR IN THE REAR CHAMBER
MISTER CHIU.
SEC YOU MISTER SPEAKER SOME
MEMBERS HAVE.
AS I'M AS A PROUD REPRESENTATIVE
FROM DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE. I IT
IS MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
TO MILPITAS HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
TEAM.
MILPITAS RECTANGULAR OUT GIVE
GIVE ALMOST A LOT OF APPLAUSE.
MOVIE THOSE TROJANS LONG TO SEE
AYE OF DIVISION FOR A STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP LAST YEAR. IN
DECEMBER BY DEFEATING ITSELF
WEST EL CENTRO BY FOUR POINTS I
DUNNO WORD THE SOUTHWEST CENTRO.
IS FROM BUT.
THAT GOES ON THE BORDER OKAY AS
THOSE ARE VERY CLOSE GAME.
ON THE FLOOR I'M JOINED BY
MILPITAS SCHOOL FOOTBALL COACH
KELLY CAME.
PRINCIPLE OF FRANCIS ROLE HAAS.
AND ATHLETIC DIRECTOR JEFF LAMB.
AND TEAM CAPTAIN.
TONY FOOT FOR FITA. AND
DIETERICH.
BREEZY AND PIRATES BRIEFLY.
THE REST OF THE TEAM IS UP IN
THE GALLERY ALONG WITH HER
ASSISTANT COACHES SO PLEASED
WAVE.
THAT THAT'S.
THE MOVIE DOES RODEOS COMPLETED
AND OUTSTANDING SEASON AND IT IS
MY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE THEM
TODAY.
THIS FANTASTIC ACHIEVEMENT WILL
WALL AS A TRIBUTE TO A LONG TERM
HAVE CODES MISTER KANE. YEAH AND
ALSO WE'RE HERE TO CELEBRATE
HIS.
TWENTY HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED M.
TOWARD TWO HUNDRED K. RIO GAMES
DURING THE SEASON.
AT.
TO THE SENIOR WHO ARE HEADING TO
COLLEGE LATER THIS YEAR. WILL
LIKE WISH YOU CONTINUED SUCCESS
IN YOUR. IN THE YEARS TO COME
EVOLVED A STUDENT WHO WILL BE
BACK NEXT YEAR. KEEP WORKING
HARD IN THE SCHOOL AND ON THE
FIELD. AND WE ALL LOVE TO
CELEBRATE THAT CELEBRATE THIS.
AGAIN NEXT YEAR
TILL THE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
AND OVERALL OFF OF LOS WHOM
REPEAT OF HIGH SCHOOL TROJANS
AND. MORRISSEY AYE ELF DIVISION
FOR A STATE CHAMPIONSHIP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE A DID
SO GUESTS WITH US TODAY I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE.
COOPER.
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
HOLDEN AND DALLY FOR A SPECIAL.
ON INTRODUCTION FROM MY DESK ON
THE FLOOR MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME YOU
TODAY. IN THE REAR THE CHAMBERS
MISS BRIANNA HOLBERG SIGNATURE
REMIND LODI MISS HOBART IS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN. TO
LEAVE THE NATIONAL FUTURE
FARMERS OF AMERICA AS PRESIDENT.
BRING US CURRENTLY A SOPHOMORE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHICO IT WILL SPEND THE NEXT
YEAR TRAVELING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY PROMOTING OUR CULTURAL
LITERACY. AND POLICIES.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE A CALIFORNIAN
AT THE HELM OF THE NATIONAL FFA
IS EVEN BETTER SHE CALLS LODI
NOT CONSIDER DISTRICT.
HER HOME. IT RIVER EVERYTHING WE
EAT AND WHERE COMES FROM ACT.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME BEING
MISS BRIANNA HOBART TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL
.
AND MISS YOUR HOLDING YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZED ON THIS GUEST
INTRODUCTION. FOOD YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LET ME ALSO JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM MILL GROVE. AND
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK.
A WELCOME MS BREANNA HOBART TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND RECOGNIZE
HER AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN.
TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA HER
WORK AND PROMOTING INCLUSIVITY
AND DIVERSITY IN THE FIELD OF
AGRICULTURE IS COMMENDABLE.
AND INSPIRING NOT ONLY SEE HOME
GROWN CALIFORNIA BUT SEE
EXEMPLIFIES THE DRIVE. REMUS
HAVE TO BOAST OUR REPUTATION AS
A WORLD LEADER AND PRODUCE THAT
OUR CULTURE WE ALSO JOIN IN
WELCOMING HER TODAY AS WELL
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GUESTS WITH US TODAY I'M GOING
TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION MR MATHIS.
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
IT IS AN ALL HONORED TO PRESENT
THIS RESOLUTION.
TO THE STRAP MORE HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL TEAM
THE SPARTANS.
LAST YEAR THEY WON THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
DIVISION SIX DOUBLE A.
STATE FOOTBALL CHAMPIONSHIP.
THIS EXCELLENT TEAM WENT
UNDEFEATED.
WITH THE SIXTEEN ALL RECORD.
THEY SECURED THE SCHOOLS.
STATE TITLE.
AS WELL AS THE FIRST TITLE IN
THE HISTORY OF TULARE COUNTY.
DURING THE CHAMPIONSHIP GAME THE
SPARTANS TOOK THE FILM.
WITH OVER SIX HUNDRED LOYAL
FANS.
WITH FOR ME COMMUNITY.
WITH ONLY A POPULATION OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
CHEERING THEM ON AGAINST THE
ORANGE COUNTY PANTHERS.
WELL THE SPARTAN SURROUNDED BY
HALF.
THE DEFENSE FORCE THE PANTHERS
TO PUNCH.
GIVING THE SPARTANS THE UPPER
HAND.
AND THE FOURTH QUARTER. THE
SPARTANS LED BY TWO POINTS.
WITH TWO MINUTES LEFT ON THE
CLOCK.
THEY ONLY NEEDED FOUR YARDS TO
CLINCH THE TITLE.
RUNNING BACK AND STRONG SAFETY.
JOSEPH GARCIA WHO RUSHED.
FOR TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN YARDS ON
FORTY THREE CARRIES. MOVE THE
BALL FIVE YARDS.
THUS ENSURING THE VICTORY.
THE UNPARALLELED SUCCESS OF THE
TEAM IS THE RESULT OF NOT ONLY
THE DEVOTION AND HARD WORK OF
THE TEAM MEMBERS THEMSELVES.
BUT ALSO THEIR FAMILIES
FRIENDS THE SHOP MORE COMMUNITY.
AN EXCEPTIONAL EXPERIENCE.
DEDICATION AND LEADERSHIP. OF
HEAD COACH JEREMY BLACK WORLD IT
IS ASSISTANCE THAT ARE HERE WITH
ME TODAY.
THEY'RE CARELESS HOURS OF
DEVOTION TRAINING NURTURING AND
COMPETITIVE SPIRIT AND GOOD
SPORTSMANSHIP. ENSURE THE
ASTOUNDING VICTORY.
THESE YOUNG ATHLETES HAVE BEEN
BILLION TOWARDS THIS AMAZING
MOMENT.
FOR YEARS.
THIS PROGRAM IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHAT HARD WORK. AND
DEDICATION CAN DO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
SCALP WERE HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
TEAM ON THEIR VICTORY LAP HERE
AT THE STATE CAPITOL. GOV
SPARTAN
I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
MEMBERS IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME MEMBERS OF THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY AND
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS TODAY THERE IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THE
DISTRICT IS THE CARETAKER OF ONE
OF OUR STATE'S MOST VISIBLE AN
ICONIC LANDMARKS THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE.
AND IS THE LARGEST PUBLIC FAIRY
OPERATOR IN THE STATE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF OUR NATURAL
WATERWAY.
CARRYING OVER TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION PASSENGERS ANNUALLY
ACROSS THE BAY FROM CLARKSBURG
TIBURON IN SAUSALITO TO SAN
FRANCISCO.
AS WELL AS OPERATORS OF GOLDEN
GATE TRANSIT CONNECTING THE
NORTH BAY AS FAR AS CINEMA. AND
SAN FRANCISCO USING RENEWABLE
DIESEL AND DIESEL ELECTRIC
HYBRID BUSES FOR APPROXIMATELY
SIX MILLION CUSTOMERS ANNUALLY.
IN OPERATION SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN EACH YEAR THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE WELCOMES OVER
TEN MILLION VISITORS TO ITS
SIDEWALKS IN APPROXIMATELY FORTY
ONE MILLION VEHICLES. CROSS ITS
ROADWAY THE BRIDGE HAS CONTINUED
WORK ON CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SUICIDE DETERRENT NET SYSTEM.
AND WILL BE MOVING FORWARD ON
ITS LAST PHASE OF THE SEISMIC
RETROFIT OF THE SUSPENSION SPAN.
AND I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU HAS SOME REMARKS I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE.
SABRINA HERNANDEZ THE PRESIDENT
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
GERALD COCHRAN A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD. DENNIS MULLIGAN THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE DISTRICT
AND AMORITE CHO LONG THE
SECRETARY OF THE DISTRICT AND
MISTER CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR ADDITIONAL RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
MATEO IN WELCOMING OUR. OF
BRIDGE DISTRICT MEMBERS OF THIS
IS.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT MANAGES NOT
JUST AN ICON FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT.
AN ICON FOR CALIFORNIA AYE AND
AS OUR COLLEAGUE JUST SAID.
THEY HAVE BEEN.
VERY SPONSORED WILL AND
OPERATING.
A DISTRICT THAT HAS ALLOWED
CLOSE TO FORTY MILLION VEHICLES.
TO CROSS OVER. THE ICONIC
BRIDGE THAT WE ALL KNOW.
AS WELL AS HELPING TO SERVE
MILLIONS WITH BOSTON VERY
SERVICE IN MY DISTRICT AND.
OUR BROADER NOR THE CALIFORNIA
REGENTS SO WITH THAT.
AND I SEE ALSO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO WE
WANT TO WELCOME YOU THINK YOUR
WORK AND TURN AFFECTED SPEAKER.
LET'S WELCOME THEM TO THE
CHAMBER
AND MEMBERS BRIEFLY I
UNDERSTAND THAT TOMORROW IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO'S.
BIRTHDAY LET'S WISH HIM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AS WELL.
MEMBERS MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS TWO
THREE FOUR AND FIVE WILL BE
CONTINUED.
ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEM SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT.
PASS AND RETAIN AND WERE ALSO
PASSING RETAINING ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE.
ON SENATE THIRD READING
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DON
BATTLE A RESIDENT OF DUBLIN HE.
STE AWAY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIRST.
HE WAS BORN ON JANUARY SECOND
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND WAS
SERVING HIS TEN. YEAR ON THE
DUBLIN CITY COUNCIL BEFORE
PASSING AWAY FROM PANCREATIC
CANCER AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY.
JOHN EARNED HIS BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING FROM PURDUE
UNIVERSITY BEFORE WORKING FOR
THIRTY ONE YEARS WITH BECHTEL
CORPORATION AS A FIELD ENGINEER.
A COST AND SCHEDULE MANAGER AND
PROJECTS CONTROL MANAGER IN THE
YEARS TO FOLLOW THOSE SKILLS
VERY WELL SERVED HIM IN ALL OF
HIS. PUBLIC SERVICE ENDEAVORS HE
WAS A DUBLIN RESIDENTS SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND A
VETERAN WHEN HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE DUBLIN CITY
COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
DURING HIS TENURE AS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER DON HELPED CREATE
NEW PUBLIC PARKS ALL ACROSS
DUBLIN SUCH AS FOUND SPORTS PARK
IN THE WAVE WATER PARK.
HE SUPPORTED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE VALAR CROSSING APARTMENT
COMPLEX WHICH PROVIDED HOUSING
FOR MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND HE WAS ESPECIALLY PROUD OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AND MOLD
FESTA THE REGION'S FIRST MIXED
INCOME HOUSING PROJECT WHICH WON
SEVERAL HONORS IN A WORDS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. HE WAS ALSO ACTIVE
ON MANY REGIONAL AGENCIES SUCH
AS THE HOUSING COMMISSION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY LIVERMORE AMADOR
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THE TRI VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY
POURED.
BEFORE JOINING THE DUBLIN CITY
COUNCIL HE SERVED FOUR YEARS ON
THE PLANNING COMMISSION AND
ALMOST THIRTEEN YEARS ON THE
DUBLIN SCHOOL BOARD HE HAS
TOUCHED EVERY ASPECT OF DUBLIN
LIFE. FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND MY
FAMILY AND EVERYONE WHO LIVES IN
DUBLIN HAS A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE IN DUBLIN BECAUSE OF DON
BATTLE.
HE HELPED A LOCAL NONPROFITS AS
WELL IN DUBLIN THRIVE AND GROW
INCLUDING THE SCHOOL OF
IMAGINATION WHICH IS A VERY
TERRIFIC PRESCHOOL FOR CHILDREN
WHO WERE ON THE SPECTRUM AND
THOSE WHO. ARE NOT SO THEY CAN
BE IN SCHOOL TOGETHER.
HE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE TWICE TRI
VALLEY YMCA AND HOPE HOSPICE.
WITH ALL HIS FREE TIME HE WAS
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE DOUBLE CAN
DUBLIN HISTORIC PRESERVATION
SOCIETY AND DUBLIN ROTARY WHERE
HE ONCE SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE SERVICE COMMITTEE.
DON WAS REMEMBERED FOR MANY OF
THE TRAITS THAT PUBLIC SERVANTS.
SHOULD ASPIRE TO WHEN HE WAS IN
A MEETING OR ANY ONE OF THESE
COMMISSIONS OR GROUPS OR
AGENCIES HE WAS NOT THE
LIGHTNING ROD THAT DIVIDED
PEOPLE. HE WAS ALWAYS THE PERSON
THAT PEOPLE WENT TO FOR HOW WE
COULD FIND A WAY AND A
CONSENSUS.
AND I JUST KNEW HIM AS
DEDICATED.
GENEROUS AND UNBELIEVABLY
CHEERFUL.
EVEN WITHOUT MANY INVOLVEMENTS
HE MANAGED TO STILL BE
INCREDIBLY CHEERFUL EVERY TIME
YOU SAW HIM IN EVERY TIME YOU
KNEW HIM AND YOU KNEW. THAT IF
YOU GOT TO BE ON THE COMMISSION
WITH HIM THERE IS GOING TO BE AT
LEAST ONE CONSTRUCTIVE PERSON IN
THE ROOM. EVERY SINGLE TIME.
JOHN IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DONNA MARIE HIS TWO DAUGHTERS
PATRICIA AND SANDY AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN NINE THE PLEASURE.
OF GETTING TO VISIT WITH THEM
AND OUR COMMUNITY MORE BROADLY
AFTER SESSION ON THURSDAY AS WE
CELEBRATED. DON'S LIFE AND THE
HOUSE WAS PACKED
THE ENTIRE SHANNON COMMUNITY
CENTER OF PEOPLE WHO'VE SEEN HOW
MUCH HE CHANGED THEIR LIVES AND
MADE DUBLIN IN THE TRI VALLEY
BETTER.
AB MEMBERS I OFFER MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO DON'S FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AND ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
TODAY ADJOURNING AND HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU DON BILL FOR YOUR
YEARS OF SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
SOME NEVER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
HE MET THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY WITH A SAD HEART.
AND TO ADJOURN INTO MEMORY OF MY
GOOD FRIEND CHILDHOOD FRIEND AND
FRATERNITY BROTHER RODERICK ROD
MAYO.
WHOSE TRANSITION ON FEBRUARY
TWELFTH AFTER SUFFERING A
MASSIVE HEART ATTACK.
I'VE KNOWN ROD SINCE JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL WE BOTH ATTENDED LOS
ANGELES HAS SCHOOL TOGETHER
WHERE.
WE JOINED THE CLUB CALLED
VOICING YOUR BOARD IN ONE DAY
WITH STAND WITH MY COUSIN VICTOR
IN HOUSTON IT WAS COUSIN DAMIEN
WE BOTH LOOKED AT ONE ANOTHER
JUST STARTED LAUGHING.
I'M NOT SURE WAS LAUGHING AT HOW
FUNNY I LOOKED I KNOW WE'RE
LAUGHING AT HOW FUNNY THEY LOOK
WE BECAME FAST FRIENDS AFTER
THAT.
WE RECONNECTED IN THE SPRING OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE FORTY
BECAME AN INITIATE OF UP SO I
CHAPTER OF KAPPA ALPHA SCI FI
TURNED EIGHTY.
WE LATER HE LATER BECAME A
CHARTER MEMBER OF LAMBDA BETA OF
CAP OFFICE
OF KAPPA ALPHA SITE AT UC
IRVINE.
IRVINE ROD WAS A ROMAN TROJAN
JUST LIKE ME.
WHICH IS A LOS ANGELES HIGH
SCHOOL ALUM AND U. S. SHEILA.
HE ATTENDED UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE SCHOOL AT U. S. C.
ACHIEVING THAT MS.
NBA IN BUSINESS AND IT M. S. AND
TAXATION.
ROD WENT ON TO BECOME A VERY
SUCCESSFUL CPA WOODY CALLING
FIRM OF PRICE WATERHOUSE COOPERS
WE VENTURE RETIRED AS A PARTNER.
THE TIME OF HIS DEATH ROT WAS
WORKING AS A LECTURER AT YOU
USC'S MARSHALL SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS.
REID HAD A BIG HEART.
HE PROVIDED MANY INTERNSHIPS FOR
A LOT AFTER AMERICANS IN THE
FIELD OF ACCOUNTING. HE WAS A
MENTOR TO MANY.
WITH THE ONE HUNDRED BLACK MEN
IT WAS A MENTOR TO MANY IN THE
FIELD OF ACCOUNTING.
RAZA SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF TEN
YEARS TRACY MAYO. TWO DAUGHTERS
RYAN AND SYDNEY A ONE SON ROD
MAILED THE SECOND. MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
JOIN IN MEMORY OF MY FRIEND
ROTTEN THEY'LL.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ANNOUNCED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF REVEREND
WILLIAM
LESSER WHO PASSED AWAY. AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE.
RIVER LESSER WAS ONE OF THE
SMALL ARMY OF ACTIVISTS WHO
ANSWER DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR'S CALL TO MARCH ON THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE ON TURN
AROUND TUESDAY. TWO DAYS AFTER
BLOODY SUNDAY.
HE RETURNED TO SELMA ON THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS LIFE
RIVER LESSER SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT THE PAT PACIFIC
LUTHERAN THEOLOGICAL SEMINARY IN
BERKELEY FOR SIX YEARS. LEAVING
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE TO
BECOME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
LUTHERANS SCHOOL OF THEOLOGY
CHICAGO.
AFTER RETIRING IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN HE MOVED BACK TO
BERKELEY SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF
THE PARLIAMENT. OF THE WORLD
RELIGIONS FROM TWO THOUSAND
THREE.
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND TEN.
HE THEN MOVED A CLAREMONT WHERE
HE CONTINUED HIS CIVIL RIGHTS IN
INTERFAITH WORK UNTIL WE
SUCCUMBED TO PROSTATE CANCER AND
JANUARY.
THROUGH THE THREAT. OF
PERSECUTION IN PREJUDICE
REVEREND LESSER APPROACH THE
FIGHT FOR CIVIL JUSTICE THE WAY
A PASTOR SHOULD.
FINDING STRENGTH THROUGH PRAYER
AND FINING GRACE THROUGH
SEPARATELY AND OTHERS DO THE
CHALLENGES GOD HAS PLACED BEFORE
THEM.
RIVER LESSER LEASE.
A BLESSED LEGACY OF RELIGIOUS
GENEROSITY AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCACY.
RIVER LESSER IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF SIXTY YEARS JEAN SONS
DAVID AND GREGORY AND THREE
GRANDCHILDREN.
MEMBERS I APPRECIATED THANK YOU
FOR AGREED TO RETURN OUR SESSION
IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
THIS AFTERNOON.
TO REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED OUR SESSION TODAY IN
THE MEMORY OF MICHAEL AG A CLOSE
FRIEND OF OUR FAMILY WHO PASSED
AWAY IN ROCKLIN. THIS PAST
NOVEMBER.
MIKE WAS ORIGINALLY FROM
MICHIGAN WAS A GRADUATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
AND AS A SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETE.
PLAYED RUNNING BACK FOR THE
WOLVERINES UNDER COACH BUMP
ELLIOTT.
MIKE TOOK HIS DEGREE IN HISTORY
AND MOVE TO CALIFORNIA AND
BECAME A MUCH LOVED AND
RESPECTED TEACHER. INITIALLY AT
AMERICAN HIGH SCHOOL
ADDITIONALLY HE COACH FOOTBALL
AT THAT SCHOOL AND WAS A REFEREE
IN THAT AREA AS WELL.
HE THEN MOVED INTO
ADMINISTRATION AND ACCEPTED A
POSITION AS A VICEPRINCIPAL. AT
PACIFIC GROVE HIGH SCHOOL IT WAS
IN PACIFIC GROVE THAT MIKE
BRIEFLY LEFT THE EDUCATION FIELD
AND HE HAD HIS WIFE OPENED A
SMALL BUSINESS.
IT WAS DURING THIS PERIOD THAT
HE WAS IN SERIOUS SERIOUS ROAD
ACCIDENT. THAT REQUIRED MANY
MONTHS OF HOSPITALIZATION BUT
RECOVER HE DID. AND RETURNED TO
THE PACIFIC GROVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHEN THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PACIFIC GROVE ACCEPTED THE
SUPERINTENDENCY IN SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO. MY JOINED HIM AS VICE
PRINCIPAL IN THE SCHOOLS IN THAT
COMMUNITY. IT WAS IN THAT
CONTEXT THAT I FIRST MET MIKE
WHO AS A COLLEAGUE OF MY
FATHER'S WOULD JOIN OTHER
TEACHERS FOR AN END OF THE YEAR
GATHERING. AT THE RUSSIAN RIVER
BECAME AN ANNUAL TRADITION. EACH
YEAR THE ASSEMBLED TEACHERS
WOULD SWAP STORIES OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR JUST CONCLUDED AND THERE IS
NO BETTER STORYTELLERS THAN MIKE
AG. EVERYTHING HE RELATED WAS
TRUE AND SOME OF IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS.
MIKE WAS A TALENTED MUSICIAN
ATHLETE AND EDUCATOR WHO COULD
CONVERSE WITH KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
ALMOST EVERY SUBJECT.
ARE RELUCTANT TO USE A PRETTY
TIRED DESCRIPTION BUT HE WAS IN
MY VIEW A RENAISSANCE MAN. WHO
IS EXTREMELY WELL READ AND
ALWAYS HAD A TWINKLE IN HIS EYE?
HE AND MY DAD SHIRT A FANTASY
FOOTBALL TEAM WHICH GAVE EACH
THE OTHER TO BLAME FOR
CONSISTENTLY POOR SHOWINGS. BUT
AS ALWAYS HIS GOODWILL AND
CONSTANT HUMOR WAS PRESENT HE
COMPLETED HIS EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY AS A PRINCIPLE OF TWO
HIGH SCHOOLS. AND AS HIS HEALTH
BEGAN TO WANE HE CAME TO THE
SACRAMENTO AREA TO BE CLOSER TO
FAMILY. HERE HE TAUGHT IN THE
FALL SOME RANCHO CORDOVA SCHOOLS
AND FINALLY IN THE ROCKLIN
SCHOOL DISTRICT. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS COMPANION DIANNE HIS
SISTER TWO DAUGHTERS AND TWO
GRANDCHILDREN. FAMILY MEMBERS
HAVE JOINED US IN THE GALLERY
TODAY ALONG WITH MY FATHER
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER. JEAN
MULLIN AND MANY OF HIS FORMER
COLLEAGUES ARE WATCHING THIS
ADJOURNMENT ON THE CALIFORNIA
CHANNEL I AM FORTUNATE. TO HAVE
KNOWN MY KEIICHI AND CALL HIM A
FRIEND HE WILL NOT SOON BE
FORGOTTEN.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
WE CHURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
CAGE.
THANK YOU.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY MARCH SIX CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH SEVENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
WILL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
TO CALDERON MOVES TO MISTER DALY
SECONDS AT THE HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTH AT NINE AM
THE QUORUM CALLS LIFTED